und in flensburg begrüße ich jetzt den
vizekanzler und
bundeswirtschaftsminister guten tag
haben
sind sie in berlin sind sie dafür wie ja
auch die usa die niederlande frankreich
und diverse andere länder zügig schwere
waffen an die ukraine zu liefern
man muss eine entscheidung treffen
kämpft die ukraine für sich und wir
helfen ihr dabei oder kämpft die ukraine
für uns ein krieg der die freiheit auch
damit europas verteidigt ich glaube
letzteres ist die klare antwort die
deutschland schon gegeben hat und immer
weiter geben muss und daraus folgt dass
aus der dynamik des krieges auch einen
dynamik der unterstützung der ukraine
werden muss und etwas anders als es
dargestellt wurde in ihrem beitrag davor
sind wir ja schon dabei uns zu kümmern
schwerer waffen in die ukraine zu
liefern also das heißt vieles was
gefordert wird das tun wir ja schon
bereits aber beispielsweise das system
das die holländer liefern die
niederländer haben wir ja auch das heißt
würden sie auch befürworten dass wir
eigene moderne westliche waffen liefern
der ringtausch denen der bundeskanzler
angesprochen hat und der in dem bericht
auch
dargestellt wurde schließt natürlich
auch die bundeswehr miteinanders wird es
ja keinen sinn machen also wir können ja
nicht anderen sagen ihr überprüft euro
bestände und wir fühlen die auf aber wir
überprüfen unsere bestände nicht und
eben abhängig von der kriegs dynamik bin
ich mir sicher dass auch die bundeswehr
und die bundesverteidigungsminister
immer wieder überprüfen wird ob wir mehr
abgeben können noch einmal wenn die
entscheidung getroffen ist dass die
ukraine nicht nur für sich kämpft und
unsere unterstützung dabei bekommt
sondern auch für uns kämpft dann wäre im
konzert mit den nato-partnern
entsprechend auch die
abgabe von material aus der bundeswehr
immer wieder neu zu prüfen und genau das
wird auch sicherlich passieren steht das
jetzt konkret an das heißt verstehe ich
sie richtig dass die dynamik bedeutet
wir müssen jetzt auch schnell mehr
liefern
schnell mehr liefern klingt schon fast
ein bisschen zynisch wir hätten
sicherlich schon viel früher und da rede
ich jetzt nicht mehr von tagen oder
wochen sondern von jahren die ukraine
auch militärisch unterstützen müssen das
ist sicherlich ein fehler der in der
vergangenheit gemacht wurde und das gilt
sicherlich auch für die jüngste
vergangenheit aber dass man nicht
schnell genug war heißt ja nicht dass
man jetzt nicht schnell werden muss der
kanzler spricht davon einen dritten
weltkrieg verhindern zu wollen gibt es
eine ansage von putin oder große stellen
wenn ihr das und das liefert dann
überschreitet ihr die linie zum
weltkrieg
es gibt keine ansage bekannt wäre nach
den internationalen bestimmungen es ist
so dass ein angriffskrieg und die
unterstützung eines landes das an einem
angriffskrieg unter einem angriffskrieg
leidet kein aktiver eintritt in den
krieg ist das heißt die unterstützung
der ukraine mit waffen ist nach dem
recht kein keine beteiligung am krieg
auch nicht mit schweren waffen aber ob
putin sich immer an recht und gesetz
hält daran kann man ja mit gutem grund
zweifeln da wird sicherlich nicht erst
einmal in das handbuch für völkerrecht
schauen bevor er seine nächste
wahnsinnstat begeht insofern gibt es
nicht die eine rote linie meiner ansicht
nach sondern wir befinden uns in einer
roten zone das abzustreiten also damit
auch die ernsthaftigkeit der überlegung
innerhalb der bundesregierung wäre naiv
das heißt aber nicht dass deutschland
aus angst und gelähmt vor dieser drohung
nichts tun kann und noch einmal wir tun
ja bereits viel wir kümmern uns darum
dass schwere waffen in die ukraine
kommen mit dem budget das bereitgestellt
wurde es ist der ukraine möglich weitere
waffen einzukaufen schwerer waffen
einzukaufen das bezieht ja auch die
deutsche rüstungsindustrie mit ein und
wir gehen aktiv auf andere länder zu ob
sie nicht schneller noch material
liefern können also das pragmatisch ist
und getan werden kann das wird getan
herr beck wenn jetzt die union im
bundestag beantragen wird schwerer
waffen zu liefern wie werden sie
abstimmen wie es die gesamteinschätzung
der ampel
ich finde es insgesamt nicht glücklich
wenn der bundestag bei zwei ähnlichen
anträgen und davon gehe ich aus dass es
zwei sehr ähnliche möglicherweise sehr
nah beieinander stehende anträge sich in
opposition und regierung zerlegt das
haben wir als wir in der opposition
waren bei den wirklich relevanten bei
den fragen von nationalem interesse auch
nicht getan
insofern hoffe ich eigentlich dass
deutschland sich in der stärke der
einheit der letzten tage und wochen
wieder zusammenfindet und auch
geschlossen und gemeinsam der bundestag
abstimmen kann ja weg ich danke ihnen
für das gespräch
ich danke ihnen